hey bruh you ready for some green eggs
and ham ting in Doug dr. Seuss's here
today you ready for that hop on pop a
lot no uh-uh-uh
horton hears a hooker oh you ever smoked
a joint forget your cousin's name dude
you ever wear one sock out the house huh
you ever done any of that you beautiful
little piece of space [ __ ] you have a
pee on your own feet in the shower oh so
warm well if you've done any of that you
are welcome here this is this this past
weekend change for the world baby cuz
I'm a dog man oh we want to be Doug
sometimes man I want to dude sometime I
want to be a thug that's trick daddy
right there thugs are us that's trick
daddy man and sometimes I do I want to
be a thug you know sometimes I just want
to wake up in the morning and just just
[ __ ] be violent and I'll say it man
I do I want to wake up and be violent
you know and I want to just shoot I want
to shoot I want to shoot the wall or I
want to just break a lamp or just
fistfight somebody in the Trap House you
know sometimes I want to live like that
sometimes I want to live like that man
how are you guys it's March 13th 2017
and and I thank you so much for joining
me this morning on this past weekend
coming to you from Baton Rouge Louisiana
I couldn't be at home today I came to
visit my
family and to go visit my friends in New
Orleans went to the st. Patrick's Day
parade yesterday that [ __ ] was
disorganized to say the least I Love New
Orleans but I do not like that parade
yesterday I mean it was so Irish dude
there was it was so it was so it was
almost Scottish that's how bad it was
dude it was pretty close to Scottish the
Scottish people are about the realest
people in the game dude I mean they are
they're thugs ma'am they're beautiful
dogs man they are beautiful they are
just the Forgotten children of the
universe they still fight with swords
you could be at a hospital in Scotland
easily a couple dudes show up with
wounds from ordinary sword wounds you'd
be like what kind of sword did you get
hit with then he's like all just a
ordinary sword dude those people are
still just fighting each other with fire
biting a lot of people biting each other
there that's the kind of place we still
get bit there you got to be on your bike
game and I guess in in in in in us too I
mean my cousin got bit by a gay guy
about a month ago or maybe yeah so so
we'll see how that works out but
thoughts and prayers with him man good
to see you guys this morning or not even
see you I want to thank you guys for the
support of the new podcast of of the the
comedy album we were number one on the
iTunes charts for a week so I mean I
never thought something in my life like
that would occur so I thank you very
much for just being a part of it a lot
of great new stuff coming out of the
pipeline I promise you and and I really
appreciate just the support you know I'm
excited to do some new things we're
doing a cool fundraiser show coming up
in rural Illinois this summer and then
next weekend I'm in Madison Wisconsin
I'm just getting these out of the way
real quick that's a brand new of brand
new March 23rd through 25th I'll be at
the comedy on state and then Tampa
Impa Florida April 6 through night and
then the 21st through 23rd I'll be in
Sacramento at the punchline so I don't
know what you're saying Patty's Day
weekend was like I came into New Orleans
it got pretty wild dude at the end of
the parade
I never saw the end of the parade first
of all because it was so broken up we
saw two floats we were there for about
five hours and it was just so there were
people at the end there was just a bunch
of drunk Irish guys kind of we were kind
of by this gay neighborhood and if you
don't know what that is
that's just a neighborhood where there's
a lot of gay people there's nothing
wrong with it it's just what it is
and you couldn't tell who was gay or who
was just really Irish because everybody
was just it was just like all adult men
just kissing each other and just jumping
on each other's backs and just you know
doing piggybacking and you know one one
guy was kind of pulling another man's
arm hair they were playing like a little
I guess just a wild game that they
tended to get into and they were I guess
part of the game was just to pull get us
you know get up under a man's arm and
just tug on that arm hair a little bit
and I didn't stay to find out what the
name was and I couldn't tell if those
men were Irish or just homosexual so you
know it's just crazy how close we all
are you know I mean if you get so Irish
you could easily wake up in bed with
another man and is that even gay or is
that just being just way Irish but I'm
here in Baton Rouge now I came to see my
family
they had a birthday party for me my
birthday is in a week so it's not now
but I'm happy to be getting close on to
another year of life they had a lot of
people come my nephew's were here that
it's got a beautiful new G Pig and so
that's beautiful cuz you know I'm in
that hamster game so I want to thank
everybody for supporting 30 pound bag of
hamster bones if you haven't checked it
out check it out and let's keep it on
the charts there
so we also went to boot crew festival
they're in New Orleans and that's of
electric disco disco music event and
that's a lot of children on drugs and
you know under the influence of just all
types of just psychedelics and
delectables that's gonna adjust your
your atmosphere you know and they were
having a good time a lot of these kids
and they had I mean just a lot of them
just look like they've just been
attacked by big just beaten with big
glitter dicks you know the the boys and
the girls just they had glitter and
bruises on their bodies you know and
just look like people have just been
beaten and with big cold just ice-cold
dicks made out of glitter and we saw run
the jewels band and that is a mixed
couple of men that get up there and
really put it together and we saw a
couple of other bands and I didn't
really get into but they had kids
dressed up like rabbits and all type of
animals outdoor animals and they were
eating chewing on pieces of plastic and
I mean like children do they were hopped
up on that dust you know they were
hopped up amid dust man and I've been
out there you know I'm not judging these
kids I've been out there you know uh I
remember one time in Las Vegas being on
under the influence of some type of
drugs and meeting this lady and she said
she was uh well she was a mystic right
and she knew where there was a warped
zone right and I was high dude you got
to be you got to be high to think
somebody knows where there's a warp zone
you know thinking back on it and she
next thing you know it's 11:00 a.m.
doing a milling around Las Vegas with
this lady
we're probably miles outside of the city
I got near some rocks and stuff and I
got scared that's when I started
sobering up and got scared and I was
pretty you know I was bent out on that
dust so I've been going through some
tough times at that point but yeah if
you know a woman she had she wore like a
parachute or a cape you know in this
lady's probably in her late 40s and you
can't you just got to be careful and
that's what I don't like about some of
those drug-induced events is that
things can go astray quickly you know
and you could end up first year with
your friends and you chewing on plastic
and having fun and next thing you know
you're out looking for a warp zone with
a woman in her you know light fifties or
or heavy 40s in the desert and so that's
really alarming stuff but that was
called buku music festival down there in
New Orleans a lot of children are on
that dust and uppers and just fragmented
their brains just some of them just
their brains just dripping out of their
eyes you know and some of it look
beautiful but I don't practice you know
drugs so that's where I'm at right now
what else I'll give you a sensual update
man I'm staying off the masturbation now
I think I have three days so obviously
that's how much of an update so but I'm
feeling full I'm feeling fuller Bellomo
you know below my tool below my pecker
really I'm feeling fuller and that's a
nice feeling you know to be walking
around with your nuts just feeling
qualified you know feeling like when I
look a woman in the eyes that you know I
could spray out if I need to you know I
could feed the family if I need to if we
hit that Great Depression and everybody
got a sip up that daddy's gonna bring a
meal to the table you know and that's a
nice feeling to walk around with your
nuts full not spent out like I'd been
doing because I've been doing
masturbation sorry I know I'm caught up
guys it's for some reason I cannot seem
to do this podcast at a regular time
it's 2:30 a.m. here Central Standard
Time but I made it here to Baton Rouge
which is where I am now it was a
beautiful birthday party man the kids
they did everything they were you know
laughing and fighting crying beatin
people was doing urine outside inside I
mean everything it was it was nice man I
mean it was beautiful you know it's just
nice nice to see children having a good
time I remember all my birthday when I
was young I had a couple of bad
birthday's actually I'm gonna had some
nice ones my mother you know made an
extra effort always to make sure we had
something
and got a nice cake because my mother
really enjoyed some cake and she would
get a little bit of canned beer and uh
when it was your birthday you got to sit
at the head of the table so it was you
know as a timer you got to feel like
this is different even in and where your
place was at the table it was a special
moment for you and my mother would drink
that canned beer and we'd have some nice
cake um I got attacked by dogs on my
birthday some of you guys know that when
I was maybe seven or eight I got
attacked by a group of dogs
one of them came at me off the roof on
us I'm not even joking her off of a
balcony next door balcony right when I
came out the door a year or two later
two of those same dogs came back and
jumped me again on my birthday
and so I've had issues with dogs you
know some animals like that we had a lot
of wild outdoor animals angry raccoons
attack tat Coons attack possums mmm what
else do we have we had just violent
animals lizards just [ __ ] little just
gangs of lizards and snails even that
looked like there was a woman in the
[ __ ] and body up so we had a lot of
wild animals in our neighborhood
anyhow I've had some rough birthdays
over the years I started drinking there
you know when I was probably 15 I
remember all and I had some issues there
with a with a brother one time actually
I wanted to get some vodka and they had
this man outs milling around outside of
the gas station loitering they call it
you know I guess in another language but
we we call it usually in America milling
around and this gentleman was milling
around and I gave him some money to get
us some some vodka and I picked him up
and he goes inside he gets the vodka and
stuff because I was underage he comes
back out gets in the car I figure I'm
gonna drive around the corner and I gave
him money as well so he could get
himself some well this man told me he
was the head-butting champion of the
world dude and this guy was a vagrant
this guy was a vagrant and I'll say this
man when you're driving a car
and there's a huge black man in the
passenger seat and he tells you and you
don't know him and he appears homeless
and gives off every indication that he's
homeless
like no indications was he giving off
that he you know received mail anywhere
regularly and he says he's the
head-butting champion of the world dude
it's alarming man and I remember I
pulled my car over because if I'm
getting head-butted bro I'm not doing it
while I'm driving you know so I pulled
the car over and he goes yeah I'll show
you and I didn't want to see I didn't
want to see but I didn't know how to
appease him and really make it out of
this situation okay so he were pulled
over and he takes my head turns it to
him rares back and it's got a big big
head looked like a mmm I'm like imagine
a big head that's dark looking and this
guy rares his head back and just bam
slams it right into my head blacked out
knocked me out unconscious definitely
the champ definitely the champ as far as
anyone I've ever met and I woke up I
came to he was gone vodka was gone and
that was it that was another birthday so
I've had some tough birthdays but this
was a beautiful one this was a beautiful
when the kids were here everybody was
here you know they had other people
brought their children and it was just
nice man it's just nice to spend some
family time together it meant a lot to
me we got a lot of great calls that came
in from people some I can't even get to
this week but I'm gonna hop into a few
of them but that was my weekend you know
I had New Orleans came to Baton Rouge
saw the family I'm going back to Los
Angeles on Tuesday next week in Madison
Wisconsin very excited and thanks again
for supporting the album let's get into
some of these calls man we had some
interesting calls come in let's check it
out
hey yeah so I'm out here important
organ I just want your purse moved up
for the last year and further expand my
social circle I started playing that
tender game on tinder I was doing pretty
good at the game for a while but um not
so long ago cannot stop looking for
advice on this because I think you have
some experience with the orgasmic
meditation mmm you see a 73 year old
woman whose name I won't say it was
probably at peace back in her day but
now she's coming in it like a strong for
well she asked me to be her stroker hmm
pardon me is intrigued and I want it or
something new like sex games and things
but I know it's a little different than
that the orgasmic meditation I don't
know if I want to have this lady laying
in my lap while I look at her bit um
might be a shallow what would you do Oh
II do you have to pay for this [ __ ] too
thank you so this gentleman is asking
based on my experience with orgasmic
meditation which is a seminar meetup
type of group that I got involved in and
I'll tell you about that in a second
he's asking what do I think about his
meeting up are being asked to join a 70
some-odd year old woman in Portland
Oregon to be part of orgasmic meditation
well my experience with orgasmic
meditation for those of you don't know
what it is it's a meet-up where men
pleasure women that they do not know in
warehouses and small areas that have
mostly cement floors and sometimes
indoor areas that are better hardwood
tile carpet this is what happened to me
I went to a seminar downtown I got
invited by an adult woman that I know
and respect a beautiful lady
she was uh in a film called pee-wee's
big adventure and she was the love
interest in it dotty is her name and she
also voiced Tommy pickles in Rugrats
she's an adult so she invited me to this
event downtown in Los Angeles she said
it's orgasmic meditation it would be
good for you so I took her word for it
and I showed up first it's the ones
people milling around having a little
bit of a fruit plate they had a fruit
plate with a couple of basic you know
delectable fruits I guess I didn't have
any of it I had coffee and then I'd
bring in a small snack amount I think
thin bar a 20 gram protein bar creamy
peanut butter so everybody sits down and
then they bring a woman up to the front
she takes her pants off takes her
underpants and then there's a man up
there he put some gloves on and he
stimulates this woman outside of her
vagina and you know basically a [ __ ]
Aereo Kitty you say kitty sorry I don't
know a lot of women don't like hearing
stuff but stimulates this lady out on
the outside of her kitty you know and
next thing you know they have other
people come up to the front of the room
who have been in the program and they
repeat the procedure where the man puts
on gloves puts like a lubricant on his
finger the woman lays down the man sits
right next to the woman the woman has no
pants on
and the man pleasures the woman for 13
minutes and then there's like a little
bit of a closing procedure at the end
now some of the women will reach climax
or orgasms some of the men you don't do
anything you keep your pants on and
everything stays natural like that and
the goal is this the man supposed to
start realizing he can get get a woman
off and he starts to carry that power
around inside of him and the woman
reaches orgasm and doesn't have to
reciprocate anything for the man
so there's some people that might sound
crazy right but I mean you know if you
do the practice you can really start
feeling pretty good so by the end of
this seminar that day downtown in a
warehouse they partner people up and
you're sitting there just stringing some
ladies beam you know you string bean and
bra you just you know doing the practice
there's a moderator walking around
there's 70 other people you know who are
laid out and just partnered up and the
men are doing their best and you can
tell what place you're coming in because
the women are you know hitting that
finish line broad just it's like a big
symphony of orgasms going off unless
you're not doing the practice well so I
mean I remember at the end of this
seminar thing they had this one dude he
was in a wheelchair you know cuz some
people just coming to meet women you
know and this is a you know this
gentleman seemed like he'd been having a
tough time he might have been a
gangbanger or something he was kind of
thug in his and his legs were really you
know aa feeble I mean his legs were
practically braided I mean he was pretty
much a gangbanger it seemed like and he
was his hair was look kind of cornrowed
up and even his legs were kind of
cornrowed almost you know just just
braided really I mean I tell what kind
of situation he was in that's how hard
he was banging I guess I don't know I
don't know his existence but I do know
that he was in there and we had to
partner him up with somebody so he gets
partnered up with this lady who was
really the prettiest lady and that I
thought visually most attractive to me
so we get him out of the wheelchair we
lay him next to the lady you know his
hands still work so he's out there you
know doing work putting in time you know
he's just just Morse code not there on
this broad and next thing you know she's
spraying out and partying you know and
not like in a in a unprofessional way
just
you know it's you're okay within the
confines of the of the practice of
orgasmic meditation to you know bring
the woman to climax so people are maxing
out all across the room and I'll say
this man for what this practice does for
people's spirit me and another guy
picked that fellow up out of his
wheelchair and laid him next to this
lady his partner that he got partnered
up with and then when we put him back in
the chair at the end of the practice he
felt he felt lighter and that may sound
crazy but this gentleman felt lighter
and that's when I felt in myself that
this practice is lifting people and so
next thing you know I'd showed up at
this thing and I'll leave that day and
I'm now I guess I'm licensed you know
I'm licensed in the practice and then
they had meetups and they still do I
don't go to him currently but they have
meetups around the city where you would
meet up and I can abandon not uh not
abandon because I sound very homeless
but you would meet up in a center like a
Center where they sold art or bad art
and you would do the practice you know
and you could meet up during the day
like you could I mean there were days
where I'd be driving across town doing
errands and stuff in Los Angeles and
then stop off you know twiddle a beam
and get you know cuz it builds up your
bravado so I walk into a lady's place
like I don't have any problem really
meeting ladies you know that's not my
issue but I wanted to see what this
experience was like and you walk in and
you beam up a girl you know just beam me
up Scotty and then you walk out and you
don't achieve any stimulation yourself
but you walk out of there after a couple
of ladies it's like you're walking
around a couple six-shooters you know I
mean you got that power and your fingers
you don't mean you're like damn Harry
Potter dude and you just you feel that
empowerment inside of you you know just
that Rebecca's zipper kasam that Vegeta
cos you know you feel like you're
capable of of bringing women to orgasm
and so you have that empowerment and the
women they get to achieve orgasm and
don't feel like they have to reciprocate
anything for the men so it's just a
feeling of them
able to feel good so anyway if you want
to get involved in something orgasmic
meditation that's what it is
sorry I've gone on so long about that
but I had to explain it to you so I will
say this my buddy from Portland who
asked about this I would get into it
because what you're gonna learn is that
that all women deserve to feel pleasure
I mean I was you know getting partnered
up with women that I probably would
never normally have talked to maybe or
forgotten or reached you know like
because you usually try to date within
your age range and stuff like these were
women I wouldn't partner up with so you
start to realize that there's some
commonality there that we all want to
feel something that we all want to feel
some sexuality so I'd give it a shot man
you know I'd give it a shot it's called
the stroker that's what it is called as
you mentioned and uh and I don't think
there's a buy-in it was free when I got
in so might be free still so get out
there and give it a shot man I'd love
for you to call back and let us know how
it was if you did have a real experience
let's hit another call man this past
weekend how you gonna feel a big fan my
name's Malik Khan from Sacramento
California and I want to ask you a
question for some advice from you oh one
thing I've been struggling with a lot of
my adult life kids anger issues I think
it stems from you know not being super
both my father growing up Plus yeah I
say believe one all the kid um you know
the late bloomer hit puberty long story
short now I'm just some 6 foot 2 215
pound ripped up black dudes piss [ __ ]
all the time you know it sucks you you
will just seem like moonship and see you
in your podcast that uh you know you you
things may get you but you don't react
violently and um I want to ask you know
what what you do to not get so [ __ ]
worked up you know when uh when things
happen in your life oh yeah appreciate
makes me Tom do
I mean I appreciate you calling in man I
mean this is you know it's tough to how
do you get rid of that childhood anger
as you become an adult you know if you
have issues with your dad you probably
were used to dealing with things on your
own if it sounds like you guys weren't
close so now you are as an adult
probably still have some childhood stuff
you're trying to deal with but at least
now you're not dealing with it on your
own you know you're talking about it you
know it's obvious you don't want to be
you know you don't want to be the angry
black guy I mean not to say that but
that's what's I mean that's the real
level you don't want to be that and you
don't want to be just an angry guy you
know and that's real man
I mean it's neat to hear that the angry
black guy doesn't want to be the angry
black guy that's what's interesting you
know because usually you see the angry
black guy you're like oh that God loves
being that guy but here he is and he
doesn't and he doesn't love being that
guy you know so it's neat to hear this
from your perspective man you know I got
a friend who's a flasher bruh i'ma say
that and it's a disease it's an illness
that he has and to hear it from his
perspective isn't is crazy cuz the last
thing he wants to be is a flasher you
know somebody that's just showin jump
you know just SJ in round town he
doesn't want that he wants to do other
stuff he actually wants to do
construction on contraction work
contractor work he wants to be a
contractor a net a licensed contractor
but he's busy caught up in the in the in
the throes of this of this flash and
because he's out there showing and it's
neat to hear this from your perspective
and you don't want to but you don't want
to be that guy so if I had to give you
some honest advice man I would say start
doing some white people [ __ ] bro get one
of those bedside things that make the
sound
ambient noise white noise they call it
that's about the whitest thing you could
do get a machine that makes white noise
you know I think that that kind of help
shake it up you tone it down
pretty much mate mostly do white people
[ __ ] these days you know I used to do a
lot of you know multicultural activities
in the day you know we used to pop off a
little bit and get a little bit Latino
and even look I get Russian sometimes
with some of these ladies but you know
now these days I'm doing I'm keeping I'm
keeping things Caucasian you know I turn
up a little bit sometimes if there's
like a if it's a playoff game oh you
know I do appreciate you calling it
sounds like you that strong bro you
strong enough to get through this take a
week off the gym and work out on what's
inside man just start working out on it
the first day you might not feel it but
you'll get there you know you'll get
there man because that's the manliest
thing that's the heaviest weights dude
is whatever's weighing on our soul bro I
swear and I know I need to work harder
on it myself I mean work with a battered
wives club or of victims of violence you
know that might show you the end product
of you know if you do feel like you have
anger and violence issues at times it
could show you the end product of that
and help you ward against you know have
a stop in your head into your mind
you'll have an end idea of what what the
effects of that behavior look like but
damn dog if there's one thing I'm afraid
of do two snakes if there's another
thing
it's Hardy brothers do that are angry
I'm saying this anybody get in there and
lift the weights but sometimes the
strongest thing you can do is lift that
[ __ ] that's off your brain you know
get in there work out that muscle
because that's so that's the irony of it
is it sometimes we get ourself
physically so in tune but all we really
want is to get that weight off of our
chest off of our shoulder you said you
might have been bullied growing up or
whatever you know I got attacked by
animals on my birthday man I don't know
if that's bullied but but it's it's wild
you know
and I don't want to see you out there
head-butting children like that man that
did me you know maybe he was you maybe
he had anger issues and he never dealt
with them and then there he is
you know 15 years later head-butting
schoolchildren for vodka you know I'm
not saying that could be you but you
know if you don't get into the gym that
brain gym that soul gym and start to
figure out what it is
things can get squirrely this.g pigs
walk it up that laptop today mmm
he's so wild boy come on dude he's
trying to use her he's trying to use a
Photoshop man he's trying to use photo
he trying to use Photoshop v20 I'm so
tired look at that look at them holes in
my face that's my eyes all right man
this past weekend all right so this is
Baton Rouge on the way out we're gonna
listen to you know it a little bit of
booze it's little boozy off with some
saggy titty and you dig is over
y'all be good man take care of
yourselves I'll see you guys next time